in this video you're going to learn how
to work with the Rational Zero test when
you're working with polynomials if you
want to find the possible rational
zeros what you do is you take all the
factors of the constant divided by all
the factors of the leading coefficient
now this only works if the coefficients
meaning the numbers in front of the
variables are integers so if they're
radicals or imaginary numbers this is
not going to work so again what you do
is you think about all the numbers that
go into 6 that would be like plus or
minus 1 2 3 6 divided by all the factors
of the leading coefficient in this case
would be one or two so you take any
numerator with any denominator so for
example it could be one over one or one
over two which is a half or two over two
which is one we listed it already three
over one three halves six over one six
over two positive or negative and these
just give us a list of the possible
rational
zeros so when we talk about the zeros
these are the x-intercepts it's where it
crosses the x-axis and the way we check
to see if there are actually uh zeros or
not is we do synthetic division so let's
just say for example I wanted to test uh
like say for example three over one
three so what we do is we do our
synthetic division we take the numbers
in front of the variables here so 2 5
negative 1 and negative 6. remember if
there's any missing terms like if I go
from X cubed to x to the first I have to
put a zero because there's a missing
term there and then what we do is we
just drop down that first
number and we multiply on the diagonal
and then we add straight down we
multiply on the diagonal and we add
straight down and we multiply on the
diagonal and we add straight down and
this last number if it comes out to zero
that tells us that 3 is a zero meaning
it's going to be an x-intercept at 3 but
in this case you can see it didn't come
out to zero so three is not a zero so
what we'll do is let's try another
quantity here let's say for example we
do one over one now I normally start off
with smaller numbers just because it
makes the calculations a little bit
easier so for example let's go ahead and
do one so we're going to take our
coefficients 2 5 negative 1 and negative
6. we drop down the first number here
too we multiply on the diagonal we add
straight down we multiply in the
diagonal we add straight down multiply
on the diagonal add straight down now
notice we're getting 0 here that tells
us that one is a zero and it's going to
cross the x axis right here at 1. now
once you do the synthetic division and
you get it down to a quadratic see how
we started with X cubed it goes down by
one degree each time so this would be 2x
squared plus 7x Plus 6. you can Factor
it or do the quadratic formula to find
the remaining zeros so in this case it
looks like we can Factor this it's going
to factor to let's see 2X and 1X and
this is going to be let's see trying to
get 7 so this is going to be
let's see what could this be here B is
going to be 2 and 3. so this way we've
got 3x and 4x which adds up to our
middle term 7x 3 times 2 is 6 and 2x
times x is 2x squared now if we set
these factors equal to zero just make
two mini equations 2x plus 3 equals 0
and x plus 2 equals zero here we can see
that x equals negative 2 is one of our
other zeros and notice that's one of our
possible zeros here see two over one
positive or negative and we can also
solve this one here this is going to
subtract 3
and divide by two so you can see that x
equals negative 3 over 2 which again
that's also one of our rational zeros so
negative 3 over 2 is like a negative one
and a half so it's going to be right
about here
and then notice that our leading
coefficient is positive so it's going to
go up to the right it's an odd degree 3
so it's going to be the opposite
direction for our left end behavior and
you can find the y-intercept by putting
0 in for X so that's going to come out
to negative 6 right here and then you
can get a pretty good sketch of your
graph it's going to look something
approximately like that
so let's take a look at another example
okay if you feel like you're getting the
hang of this see if you can try example
number two here we've got 3x cubed minus
10x squared minus 9x plus 4. we want to
find the possible zeros and we want to
test to see which ones are actually the
zeros of this polynomial now remember in
order to apply this rational zero test
or this rational root theorem as it's
sometimes called or this p over Q we
want to make sure that these
coefficients are integers okay so you
want to make sure they're all positive
or negative whole round numbers we don't
want any fractions radicals imaginary
numbers like that otherwise it's not
going to work
and then the next thing we want to do is
we want to take all the factors of the
constant that's just this number here by
itself divided by all the factors of the
leading coefficient that's this number
here in front of the highest powered
term so all the integers that go into 4
positive or negative is going to come
out to 1 2 and 4 divided by all the
factors of the leading coefficient
that's just going to be one and three
now let's go ahead and write them all
out this time so we're going to have
let's see we're going to have a a
negative 3 no not negative three sorry
we've got uh let's do them in order
let's do the posit ones first we have
one over one which is one uh we've got
one third
we've got two
we've got two-thirds which would be
right here trying to put them in order
we've got four over one which is four
we've got four over three
which is four thirds or one and
one-third and it could be positive or
negative so I could actually for all
these I'm just going to write plus or
minus okay positive or negative
so now let's test them out let's see
which ones are actually zeros so say for
example I'll start with a small number
again let's say like one
so we're going to do our synthetic
division we've got three negative 10
negative nine and four we drop down that
first number that's okay when you do
synthetic division that's the only thing
that's a little bit different you just
have to drop down the first number then
you just repeat this process of
multiplying on the diagonal add straight
down multiply on the diagonal add
straight down multiplying the diagonal
add straight down and if this last
number is zero that tells you that one
is a zero or an x-intercept but in this
case it didn't come out to zero so one
is not a zero so let's go back to the
drawing board let's try maybe negative
one so we've got negative one and again
we write down our coefficients three
negative 10. negative 9 and 4 and
remember if there's a missing term or
there could even be two missing terms or
three missing terms you have to put a
placeholder a zero so we just follow
that process of dropping down the first
number and then you multiply on the
diagonal and you add straight down you
multiplying the diagonal you add
straight down you multiply in the
diagonal add straight down now see how
we're getting zero remainder that tells
us that negative one is a zero meaning
it's going to cross the x axis right
there at negative one
and it drops it down from X cubed to x
squared when you do that synthetic
division now if it was say it was just X
cubed you might want to try and do
another one of the zeros or even try
negative one a second time the you want
to bring it down to a quadratic ideally
because you can then Factor it or do the
quadratic formula to find the remaining
zeros now sometimes if it's a cubic you
might be able to factor it by grouping
or another technique
but for this one it looks like we're
down to a quadratic so let's see if we
can Factor this so
how would we Factor this let's see it
looks like it's going to factor to 3x
and 1X that multiplies to 3x squared and
let's see negative 4 and negative 1 that
multiplies to 4 and then the inside
negative 1X and outside negative 12x
adds up to our middle term negative 13x
now if we set these equal to zero make
too many equations three x minus one
equals zero x minus four equals zero add
4 to both sides you can see x equals 4
is a zero
and if we solve this equation add 1 to
both sides and divide by 3 you can see
we're getting x equals 1 3. so so that's
going to cross right here
now if we want to get a good sketch of
our graph we know that the leading
coefficient is positive that tells us
about the right end behavior it's an odd
degree which means it's going to go the
opposite direction if it was an even
degree it would go the same direction as
the right end behavior but in this case
it's odd so it goes opposite if we put 0
in for X we can solve for a y-intercept
which is going to be 4 right here and
now we can get a pretty good sketch
of our graph
like that now you might be saying Mario
why did you go to here why didn't you
just go down to here or uh you know that
kind of a thing that's what you're going
to learn about when you get into
calculus we're going to talk about how
to find the turning points or the Maxes
or mins but for right now this video is
focusing more on how to find the
possible rational zeros how to test them
and realize that they're the
x-intercepts so if you want some more
examples you want some more practice
follow me over that video right there
and we'll get some more practice I'll
see you in that video